wait a second we could do
this when boats planes and trains get
stuck should mayor Pete only get a buck
late Tuesday the house of reps approved
a measure to slash Transportation
secretary Pete Budaj salary to
$1 down from his current pay of
$235,600
so wait we're actually paying that guy
guess that means Pete's only meaningful
income now is from his paper route but
yeah just one lousy measly dollar
usually to make that kind of money you
have to work for
me Margery Taylor green introduced The
Measure to punish Pete for using his
office to focus on woke BS like equity
and racist roads instead of actual
Transportation stuff so when you're
trained der rails at least you could be
happy the engineer is a trans
neurodiverse woman of
color
watch deserving an uh taxpayer funded
paycheck is about Job performance not
about personalities or identity politics
this is about defunding his paycheck to
a dollar which I think is a Dollar too
high American taxpayers don't want to
pay for Pete Budaj to get awards for the
way people have
sex so wait there's an award for the way
people have
sex guess we know won't ever win that
award
huh
now it's not the first time the house
has voted to slash Administration
official salaries to a dollar they did
it before to DHS secretary Alejandro
mayorcas and defense secretary llo
Austin but it didn't go anywhere and
it's never actually going to happen to
Mayor Pete so like a train under Pete's
leadership the idea is dead in its
tracks but if Biden can simply decree
that we pay for canceled student loans
which is unconstitutional by the way why
can't the house cut cabinet secretaries
pay or at least reduce it to something
more in line with their abilities like
say a $50 Amazon gift card so I say SL
Pete's salary to a dollar and make him
earn his money the oldfashioned way by
accepting illegal payoffs from
China FYI there's also a provision to
cut Karen Jean Pierre's salary to a
dollar which is unfair because according
to the pay cap it should only be 82
cents there you go
sex J do you think we're being unfair to
Mayor Pete yes I mean I'm enjoying it
you like the the hypocrisy side of me
does enjoy it but of course a Deal's a
deal we got to give him his money it is
a little bit frustrating that we can't
do something with some of those
appointed positions I mean you really do
feel like a lack of power I will tell
you when Obama got elected he was a very
smart guy and people liked him including
myself but the most confusing thing he
did was putting Joe Biden in like none
of us could really make sense of that
we're going hey what are you doing with
this guy he's supposedly a foreign
policy expert and it's like just cuz you
know the difference with Iraq and Iran
does not make you a foreign policy
expert but but in all fairness the same
thing goes with Buddha jedge you know he
cuts a pretty good promo he gets a
little bit vicious here and there he
grits his teeth and you get his crazy
look in his eye when he loses his temper
all of a sudden they appointed him and
he wasn't anything more than a mar and I
mean I'm just suggesting for you that it
is aggravated but we owe him his money
yeah well you know cat this again is
something that goes nowhere but it does
re put the spotlight on the fact that
he's inept and isn't that worth
something yeah again it it it does go
nowhere it is interesting I didn't know
this was a thing yeah I didn't know what
else can they do can they vote to like
take your phone away they like you get
grounded basic I was very confused by it
but also you know I'm sure everybody
already knows this but the politicians
don't get rich from the salary that they
make in their job they get rich from
being a politician and you know all the
the influence they become the
celebrities of sorts which is a very
strange and weird thing especially
because he doesn't really seem to have
Charisma no none at all it's a shocking
lack of Charisma yeah it's not it's like
he's not even there yeah yeah he's like
the most
[Laughter]
[Applause]
everyone else gets credit for who they
sleep with it sounded cool when you said
I'm AED right I'm not you know well you
do have if anybody ever accuses you
anything say yes CU you breed animals
yeah well calling my children that sir
is
disrespectful stop listening and me talk
to them on the phone wouldn't it be
great if we could reduce our salaries so
they'd actually have a second job no no
Greg we're doing this the wrong way and
sorry Marjorie should be the last one to
be going after anyone for being weird
okay we got to watch our own tense too
sometimes you keep like no no no not no
microphone today Mar you
go let's not mess with their salaries
okay let's audit
them oh I might get shot for that a bad
idea but instead of taking his pay to a
dollar let's see what he's been doing
okay because we know he had like a 8mon
maternity leave M and as many kids as I
have that means I should get like four
years I should be able to take a
break um he was a ghost when the trained
real went down and then when he did show
up he was in dress shoes yes remember
that he was in dress shoes so he was not
there to do the job and one on the
offense remember that he was talking
about Trump uh you know had changed some
policies I remember that it very
offputting yes and no one can get
anything off a boat or in a truck in
this country so let's just see what he's
doing with his money so start auditing
these politicians and I guarantee things
will change real quick so and we can
don't we have like 7,000 new uh IRS
something 80,000 with pistols hacking so
let's just start audit them let's vote
for that but they won't start hitting
him with audits no Charlie he has to be
the worst
Transportation secretary
Transportation I did that by accident
sure because he's the only one we've
ever heard of it's not like we've I
don't think we've ever talked about a
transportation secretary this much no
because what was your opening when you
your tease for the segment this what was
it I don't remember that but I
understand what you're saying because
he's diverse he's he's diverse for sure
I'm actually really disappointed because
I'm I'm from Indiana I've said that on
the show a few times I'm I'm really
disappointed at at who our public
figures are as far as politicians go
these days I mean we Mike Pence yeah we
had Pete but jeds also thumbs down uh so
it just you know makes me feel like we
don't have proper representation from
the good State uh but Larry Bird Larry
Bird's a good one um Larry who doesn't
like Larry Bird listen as well well as
auditing I think we also should have a
hidden camera following him because you
talk about you know transportation and
and he wants to portray himself as being
oh I'm here to promote you know clim the
climate agenda bicc ride oh that was
epic yeah where he literally took a
bicycle out of a massive SUV and then
rode to the cabinet meeting with someone
was videotaping him and I also love he
did the extra Touch where he put the
helmet on because let's be honest as a
gay man your appearance really matters
into even mhm mess with your hair even
in the slightest that was respectable
yeah I thought he was making fun of the
president we did it like look I can't
crash yeah look at
me yeah but I mean he's presided over so
much chaos and that's and that's made
him the most famous Transportation
secretary ever which Infamous Infamous I
think there will forever be a hyphen
Transportation Transportation even
though even though I don't think that's
the case hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else